if you're a Rick and Morty fan you
probably think you know all there is to
know about the show from its obscene
origins to the fan theories about evil
Morty in the truth of dimension c-137
but show creators dan harmon and justin
roiland have admitted that there are
aspects of the show that they'd probably
never reveal leaving dozens of Rick and
Morty mysteries unanswered so what do we
know about Adult Swim's most popular
animated series are you ready to dive in
and find out Oh
rhetorical question Morty the answer is
yes you just have to be a genius House
of Cosby's where would the animated
television world be without Rick and
Morty co-creators dan harmon and justin
roiland Believe It or Not fans that Bill
Cosby to thank for bringing the pair
together sort of he wasn't Cosby man at
heart it's clear he searched and found a
Cosby hey in 2005 roiland created the
House of Cosby's an animated series
focusing on a Bill Cosby superfan who
builds a cloning machine to replicate
the now ostracized comedian roiland
submitted House of Cosby's to Harmons
channel 101 film showcase and the rest
was history
[Music]
you know royland said those early
endeavors managed to earn a cease and
desist letter from Bill Cosby's lawyers
but Harmon knew we wanted to work with
royland in the future it was a letter
from Cosby's camp that prompted roylene
to come up with the real animated
adventures of doc and Marty as a form of
protest which took other beloved
characters and made them do horrible
things doc and Marty of course would
eventually become Rick and Morty oh man
my kites in the tree Doug I'm so sad
don't be sad Marty we'll go back in time
Harmon told the Los Angeles Times that
when Adult Swim approached him about
creating a series for the network he was
positive a collaboration with roylene
would be perfect saying I thought about
Justin because he is the Adult Swim
brand he is the target for a lot of
their stuff and he is also like me
really passionate about story and
franchise
I'm gonna tell you where to stick it
because you got it see that sounds too
sober oh it doesn't sounds great I know
my leman spontaneous pilot immediately
after Harmon and roylene's sold their
pitch to Adult Swim the duo got started
on writing a move that was spurred by
Harmons involvement as showrunner on the
NBC comedy community with the knowledge
that schedules would be tight Harmon and
roylene knew that time was of the
essence and so they wrote the pilot in
just six hours speaking with the Los
Angeles Times Harmon reflected on that
with quick first writing session saying
roylene and I were sitting on the floor
crossed light with laptops and I was
about to get up and go home and he said
wait if you go home it might take us
three months to write this thing stay
here right now and we can write it in
six hours he just had a premonition
about that roylene described the process
is kind of lightning in a bottle feeling
that he and Harmon needed to get the
story out right then and right there
suffice to say countless Rick and Morty
fans are glad they did the accidental
catchphrase what started out as an
off-the-cuff remark has turned into an
ironic yet iconic catchphrase used to
say on a show well Rick first use Wubba
lubba dub dub to punctuate a gag the
true origins of the phrase are later
revealed in my people's tongue it means
I am in great pain please help me
but contradictory to the phrase is
troubling true meaning in the show and
much like its rise to prominence
Rick's Wubba lubba dub dub was entirely
accidental you know talking about Morty
Morty that's my catchphrase remember
remember how I cemented that catchphrase
the line was a last minute rewrite
originally intended to be a reference to
a bit from the Three Stooges and then
later revised to refer to Arsenio Hall
when roylene new voices Rick hopped in
the recording booth he got confused by
all the changes and decided to spit the
line out wrong on purpose he explained
the mix-up it was scripted as
parenthetical Larry or Moe from the
Three Stooges
blah blah blah and Rick was gonna fall
on the ground and do that circle thing
they do and in the recording that was a
last-minute rewrite that I didn't read
and I just didn't know what the I was
looking at and I just did it wrong I
thought it would be funnier if if he
didn't get it right
he's like isn't that what our city oh
isn't that the Arsenio thing one beloved
of dubs Arsenio
of course the whole woof-woof thing is a
tried and true cartoon tradition just
with a Rick and Morty spin mental
illness the timid grandson and the super
genius grandpa pair aren't just rooted
in the Back to the Future trilogy they
grasp onto a darker more complex
foundation as well on the Rick and Morty
season 1 DVD commentary Harmon describes
the pair as an accurate personification
of bipolar disorder with Rick being the
manic side of the brain and Morty being
the depressive oh geez Rick it makes
sense given how Rick and Morty are able
to maintain a generally functional
relationship despite being vastly
different by the sounds of it
Rick and Morty could very well be two
halves of one home adding a mind-blowing
notion of the series already rich
complex universe you're a perfect
impenetrable suit of human armor Morty
because you're as dumb as I am smart
which is why when I say shut up it's
really good advice the classic theme
song
Rick and Morty is jam-packed with sci-fi
references from obscure seventies flicks
that center around massive floating
heads to movies that star freaky horror
insects to imbue the out-of-this-world
vibes of the genre into every nook and
cranny of the show Harmon and roiland
turned to two beloved television series
when crafting the theme song Rowland
revealed the TV Overmind that Doctor Who
and Farscape were the biggest
inspiration saying I told Ryan elder I
was a big fan of Farscape and then I
wanted to combine farce capes theme with
Doctor Who's theme and that's basically
what our theme song is it's this amazing
original piece that takes the best
aspects of those two themes and mashes
them together the end result is a trippy
track that roylene calls super sci-fi
what's in Rick's flask fans have long
debated what Rick's drink of choice is
including delectable sounding galactic
cocktails like super seed juice and pan
galactic gargle blaster from
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy and
even 200 proof alcohol but Harmon has a
wildly simple theory saying I tend to
assume vodka apartments fully aware that
such an earthly drink seems out of
character for Rick as he could easily
use sci-fi tech to augment anything he
sips but Harmon believes Rick's
addiction to his flask
anchors his identity saying I think the
reason he doesn't do that is because
you're a little afraid to lose sight of
who he is so we sort of know which drink
Rick is tethered to I have a lot of
vodka then I'll take one of those but
will we ever know why he started
drinking in the first place short answer
no according to Harmon roiland has
argued that revealing that part of
Rick's backstory would be very shark
jumpy likening it to finding out that
the Fonz from happy days didn't always
wear leather jackets cuz I'm the Fonz
the worst episode ask any Rick and Morty
fan what their favorite episode is and
they might tell you a ricky'll in time
the episode is popped up on numerous
best-of lists held in high esteem for
its coexisting timelines overlapping
possibilities and nuanced commentary on
morality but there are two people who
weren't so keen on it the guys in charge
Harmon and roiland before a ricky'll and
time became a fan favorite it was a
daunting project for the co-creators as
it was the introductory episode after a
15 month hiatus between the first and
second seasons roylene confessed to
Rolling Stone that the whole process
was just brutal and that it nearly
defeated him and Harmons saying it broke
us to a certain extent we were so close
to something amazing and we never really
got there from a structural standpoint
Hartmann agreed admitting that he and
royal and genuinely thought it would be
the worst episode of the second season
saying it went off the deep end
conceptually and got really over
complicated we're pretty convinced that
the first episode might be the worst for
that reason considering the episodes
focus on uncertainty it's actually kind
of ironic that Harmon and roiland were
sure it'd be a flop and were proven
completely wrong Harmons divorce during
production of the show's third season
Dan Harmon was going through a divorce
from his now ex-wife Erin McCarthy a
podcast host artist and comedian the
pair became engaged in December 2013 and
married in what appeared to be a
hilarious unique and love-filled wedding
at the Los Angeles Natural History
Museum the following November less than
a year later however McAfee dropped a
bombshell on Twitter confirming that she
and Harmon were splitting up while
divorce in any circumstance is difficult
there's something devastating about
Harmons from a Cathy in relation to Rick
and Morty after the series and credits a
series of silly splash screens appear
one of them being Harmons own vanity
card that reads harmonious claptrap in
scribbly childlike handwriting in the
first two seasons of Rick and Morty the
slate features clay versions of Harmon
and Magothy snuggled up on the couch
watching television with a cat on their
lap and a dog panting happily on the
floor post-divorce there's a new Vande
card that shows Harmon sprawled out on
the same couch alone with a bottle of
liquor in his hand and booze strewn all
over the floor
it's an image harrowing enough to break
your hearts ladies room for the first
two seasons the Rick and Morty writing
staff was predominantly male and was
described as a very very tiny little
writers room with a lot of heavy lifting
from everybody but the series group of
scribes knew that they needed a shake-up
you think it's efficient to get rid of
women you ever see a line for the men's
room are you jealous
you hear me summer season three saw the
first gender ballast writers room in the
show's history and both Harmon and Royal
and credit female writers for playing a
massive role in how the third season
panned out not only did they help ease
self-doubt behind the scenes and
contribute to a renewed creative energy
the female
also a loud room for everyone to pitch
ideas for Beth and summer storylines
Hartmann explain when you have a mixed
room it's not about the women going
here's a bunch of secrets about women
it's more about everyone being freer to
just pitch randomness so the result is
you see cool stuff happened with Beth
and summer this season thanks girls you
know you girls are really suited
something I'll tell you that you know
who and we first got here I was gonna
ship now thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all the school
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]